give you a whole bladder all to yourself
there's no power like that at all I'm
gonna be able to eat my lunch now that
I've even though odd guy Richie I'm Will
Smith this is snek Wallace XL XL
integrity is important here guys okay
meaning meaning when you taste it yeah
you have to be honest that the American
is better
oh that's sort of can you imagine I
recognize that's this when you recall
fish and chips
do you recognize that I want you to
experience okay so you see what's
happening in got a sloppy joe right and
I'm gonna cut you what I think is the
best piece for you so there you go and
it take you tips what we're after
integrity is what we're after on case
that all right do I need the mushy peas
well it's just sort of independent so
let's go ahead I mean integrity being
named the game today it's clearly the
Union Jack there's no way that you think
a piece of fried fish with some peas was
just better than a world-class sloppy
joe I'm sorry there's every way I pay
out just sloppy joes to all over the guy
you know what is doing draw this is
ridiculous you don't even understand the
depth and power of sloppy joe over I can
tell you the history of fish and chips
it comes from the kind of aristocratic
roots sloppy joe sloppy joe
all right so that was okay there was
this mess there was this messy dude
named Joe here we go yeah Hagi's that
lost already I'm not one to judge a book
by it's cover but I'm not reading that
this is this is meatloaf that's a
British bomb - that's very good I'm a
turtle I mean it's fine it's fine
that it looks like Sigourney Weaver like
deliver death it's made out of the
bowels of a sheep or something like that
and it's all wrapped up in the slider of
a pig give you a whole bladder all to
yourself oh yeah if you call it a
bladder and it's on a plate it laws it's
not boring it's not boring I'm gonna I'm
gonna eat the bladder and everything
there's no bowel like that at all now
let's roll on that it turns me life is
boring I love that bad I'm not gonna be
able to eat my lunch now that I've been
there
we need Swiss judges you're gonna lose
this one this is not fair just cuz it's
pretty you got a little gold sauce on
top
this isn't set up your own one over
there boys you try 30 he's green with
jealousy that's good that was good
no I mean tell Chester Twinkie
it's just drinking it's like not fair
never come out of a microwave where with
the asterisk that the Brits have
prepared the competition special
literally dealers yeah this is a British
attempt at a Philadelphia cheesesteak
I'm gonna taste it first and make sure
they captured the essence you should
concede this one right now jellied eels
but it's pretty esoteric yeah I mean
that could be too interesting for the
American palate over here that would
lose in the ocean like there are fish
never swim past that sorry what's this a
Philadelphia Philadelphia cheesesteak
it's a part of it sort of kids food
really for kids and kids at heart sadly
we're gonna lose this one god I have to
tell you I mean I love real I love jelly
the temperature could you
there is no friggin temperature would
happen become tasty right right at the
point where it turns from gas to plasma
is there a way you're supposed to eat it
yeah just watch out for the bone in the
middle heater close-up so what is this
again tell me God with this in last
jellied eel jellied eel wow that's awful
yeah it's definitely an acquired taste
isn't a quadtest this is no way you
think jellied eel well I'm sorry for
sophistication
we've nicked this
he's being paroled we saw two different
fights it okay but is this the
categorizing sophistication I start with
Chu melody this is Will Smith and this
is Guy Ritchie and this has been snack
wars for libel I mean you can't have a
competition without singing our National
Anthem
Oh whose broad stripes and bright stars